trust has already said and she's
committed to very large
tax cuts those are to corporation tax
and to
national insurance mainly that's about
saying that she doesn't agree with the
tax rises that rasheed either put in
place or was about to put in place when
he was
chancellor so she's got a big package
there on top of that obviously the
global economy developments with gas
prices mean she's already put in place
very big measures increasing borrowing
very significantly over this year and
next to pay for support for households
and the support for businesses that
you've been discussing on the program
this evening and then on top of that
we've got a deterioration in the economy
which means that we're seeing higher
interest rates and higher inflation and
that will lead to higher borrowing on
its own so the combination of all three
of those means that what we're going to
learn about on friday is a very very big
increase in government borrowing and how
concerned should we be or not about a
big increase in government borrowing
i mean your listeners and viewers are
probably used to hearing over the last
few years very large borrowing figures
because that's how we got through the
pandemic and obviously the financial
crisis before that also included large
amounts of borrowing as we had to
nationalize
some of our biggest banks so i think you
know there are reasons you need to do
that i think what we're seeing though is
a choice here it it's pretty much
unavoidable that we were going to be
doing more borrowing as the economy
slowed but also that we would do more
borrowing to cope with these truly
exceptional increases in energy prices i
think it's completely reasonable that
the government's saying look
some of these energy price rises are
likely to be temporary and so borrowing
from tomorrow's taxpayers to help
today's bill payers makes good sense
what they're doing on top of that though
is not doing as much as they could to
mitigate how much borrowing that help
with energy bills requires either by
going further on windfall taxes or
actually by capping the windfalls that
companies are making particularly
renewable or nuclear electricity
generators who are seeing big windfalls
even though they don't have anything to
do with uh gas oil
production and then on top of that she's
saying now's the time for large for
lower taxes than my predecessor thought
we needed so there's things that are
unavoidable about higher borrowing but
then on top of that she's making choices
not to minimize some of the increase in
borrowing and then on top of that to to
choose to have lower taxes too i mean i
guess what liz trusts his uh team would
say is that this is all part of trying
to inject growth into the economy so
lower track tax as they hope will
stimulate
growth some of the energy changes will
help bring down inflation all of these
things will a good news for the economy
i mean do you think there's merit in
that argument
it was definitely meriton saying it's a
good idea for the british government to
be focused on growth the last 15 years
have been a period of relative decline
for the uk economy we've been outgrown
by
most other
major advanced economies and that is
making us all poorer the bottom the
middle and the top are all worse off
because of that slow down in our economy
so she's right to focus on that and
she's right to say that that will
involve doing some unpopular things
cutting taxes isn't actually that
unpopular a thing you're um
recognizing also the level of taxation
isn't the most important thing in
determining your growth rates lots of
the economies that have grown faster
than us have higher rates of tax and the
united states has significantly lowered
rates of tax and has grown fast enough
so i think the role of tax in driving
economic growth is understated compared
to for example firms being able to build
things when they want to or us having
the right levels of skills in our
workforce or indeed the right numbers of
workers and actually firms investing
is important for our growth rates but it
isn't really lower corporation tax that
tends to drive that i just want to have
a look at a couple of uh charts uh if i
may and the first one
is this is from the uh resolution
foundation so hopefully you'll be quite
familiar with them the first one shows
the impact of the policy changes
introduced by liz trust in 2022-23
and then just quickly to go to the next
one because this is the one that's
really interesting the second year 2023
to four really shows here how the
planned policy changes do
disproportionately help richer
households so if you like if you like
the ones towards the richer scale the
number 10 the richest households are
benefiting most from those policy
changes
i mean list trust at least has been
quite open about this hasn't she uh to
say that she doesn't necessarily think
that it's a problem if the wealthier
households disproportionately benefit
from some of those
yeah
policies
mean what those charts show is firstly
there's a lot of support going in from
that's being announced by this trust but
it was also put in place by the previous
government under boris johnson and
russia sudan there's a lot of support
going in with a number of different
measures overall this year that's
providing quite a lot of support to
low-income households middle-income
households and high-income households
it's providing roughly the same support
to all of those income groups even
though obviously it's lower-income
households that will be suffering most
from rising energy bills they don't have
savings to draw down on they can't cut
back on expensive holidays to pay the
energy bill now if you look at next year
the chart you're showing
now you're right that when you combine
the dropping away of lots of the support
that's more focused on the bottom in the
middle this year and then you add on top
and you have a energy price guarantee
that's the price cap the 2 500 price cap
for
households and the energy bills that
goes to everybody but you add on top of
that the big cup to national insurance
that they're planning to announce on
friday then it is the higher income
households that see most support
next year they have now liz just has
said that the national insurance
rise that she wants to reverse she
recognizes benefits richer households i
think whether or not you believe in that
level of national insurance you want it
up or you want it down i think what it
definitely isn't is a good way to target
support at people during this cost of
living crisis i think there are good
arguments for a higher level of taxes
thank you very much indeed uh torsten
belva